hello and welcome to the third and
probably the last major video in CSV
manipulation within Python unless I get
a specific request or something so where
we've left off is I've shown you guys
how to at least row by row add a column
that was dependent on another variable
in that same row so you're able to make
a new variable in that row based on a
variable in that same row but something
a lot of people tend to like to do with
spreadsheets is use something maybe from
a previous row as well
and so that's what I'm going to do in
this video show you guys how you would
go about maybe including previous rows
or to systematically go through and
include data so what we're going to do
is basically what I would like to do is
for every row we're just going to add
this current variable Plus this variable
and add a new piece of data like here
right so this will be end up being 45 65
plus 666 and then do the exact same
thing here 23:48 plus 45 65 and then the
same thing here and so on so kind of a
silly example but just trying to show
you guys that not only can you
manipulate based on stuff within that
same line but we can actually go to
previous lines and use that data some
people want to you know the horizontal
manipulation is useful but a lot of
people like to do the vertical
manipulation as well so I'd hate to
leave that out so I'm going to close out
of this and actually I'm going to go
ahead and delete it because we're going
to make a new one here pretty quick so
first thing to consider is like say
we're it's kind of like a moving average
right you can't calculate that data on
an impossible row that has no previous
data so like let's say you are adding
five of the previous rows you would have
to start at row six to add the previous
spot and so in the same sense since
we're only going really like one back we
really just need to start at row two or
index value of one the next thing that
we want to do is so X is equal to one
and then for each date and date to
negative one that's great but we also
need to be X
two negative one so we start at that
point now let's go ahead and edit this
line and just so this line isn't like a
mile long let me write out the code here
for what we want to add to it we're
going to say plus bar because the
variable has addition to it and plus bar
in here will be something plus something
and in our case is going to be int Barb
X wherever X is minus one so the
arbitrary value minus 1 right because
this isn't minus one so that goes the
previous one and then that value we
could we could do the whole plus three
thing here as well but let's not and
then in here we'll just do it barb X
okay so this adds those two arbitrary
values together so that's plus form now
keep in mind that is this will throw out
an integer so we should probably in the
end convert it to a string awesome lots
of parentheses so we know we're serious
business when we do that so now save
line awesome awesome awesome but now we
actually want to plus that whole comma
and then plus something else and right
in here we're going to add the variable
now so plus quotation comma quotation
plus variable and then plus the newline
and the variable that we're adding now
it's plus mark now of course we don't
want to forget that we actually land
this not only ate a year but also in our
last line right the final line we want
to add that so just copy and paste that
part to the end and give her that extra
plus so now as long as we haven't made
any sort sort of serious typo or
anything that should work so let's run
and I'll drag this down type in name no
error
let's check the file eight cool so sure
enough we do have what appears to be the
correct amount it's kind of hard to know
at least on the first one but for the
second line to know whether or not we
were true is 23 45 plus 45 60 to eat
the 60 907 will yes indeed it is so that
you can see we use data from another row
and that's how we how we can get away
with doing that so hopefully that was
helpful to you guys obviously you can do
way more stuff besides the basic
examples that I've shown you but that's
the methodology at least that I would
suggest you use with CSV manipulation
although also there are otherwise other
ways to read CSV files within Python
numpy is just a good example in my
honest opinion for a few reasons one
this methodology can be used for
graphing very simply a lot of people
like to graph the information that's
located within their CSV file so load
text is useful for that purpose numpy is
also useful as its name suggests it's
numbers plus Python right and what numpy
is a import for python because python is
a single threaded application so you
can't actually do what's known as like
parallel computing and it's actually
with with small files you would never
notice the performance difference but
with very large like gigabytes plus size
files you'll notice that pythons
performance is relatively slow
what numpy does and as far and also a
lot of other things that you can use
within Python is it incorporates a bit
of C into it and it allows you to do
things that close to like seeds speeds
to where you get a lot more performance
out of it yet Python it's so simple to
understand you can pair what we just did
in Python - what did how you would do
this within C um it would look way more
confusing and make much less sense at
the outset anyways at least for an
amateur so anyway that's that that
should cover everything you might want
to do or at least examples of simple
versions of all the things you might
want to do you have a specific request
feel free to make one and I'll try to
make a video for you as always thanks
for watching thanks for your support
your subscriptions and until next time